hey it's Friday and it's time for
another movie retrospective and I am so
so excited that we're finally getting
around to doing this movie I've been
wanting to do this movie for how long
I've been bugging even 18 months it's
like yeah I'm just careful to use dates
right let's buy it let's do this movie
but it's like I probably could have
reviewed it without seeing it again but
I'm glad that we bought it and yeah I
never could find a good deal on it on
blu-ray so I had to give the detail
widescreen DVD which that was that was
good enough but it turns out that scream
factory scream Factory is actually
putting I just found this out today is
actually putting out a special edition
blu-ray it's coming out on October 23rd
and it's gonna have all the special
features that for whatever reason cuz
the DVD we got they don't have any
special for the trailer I think that's
all that's on there yeah now the UK
release which came out in 2007 or 2009 I
can't remember that had like an hour and
a half documentary about the making of
this movie yeah because this is like an
all-star team of people who made this
movie there's my half of the story is
what would happen behind the scenes yeah
it's a great movie and it's like it's
it's cool because this this is what
happened this is Creepshow it came out
and if you don't love Creepshow i don't
know what the [ __ ] is the matter with
you so maybe they haven't seen it this
is a [ __ ] is so fun it's so
entertaining it's like really it's
really cool to look at very well-crafted
80s it's just an awesome awesome movie
yeah and I think I first I don't think I
was 10 years old when this came out I
came out in 1982 and the theaters
actually did pretty well that was Warner
Brothers best received horror movie that
year made the most money but I don't
know if I saw it in the theater I very
well could have because my parents did
take me to see some horror movies when I
was about that age but if I didn't see
it in the theater then I definitely saw
it on home video or on HBO when it came
out in 83 or 84 and I taped it and I
watched it over and over and over again
so I told him I was like when we do this
review I said I don't even need to see
it again because
like memorized yeah even though I
haven't hadn't seen it for like 15 20
years but we bought it anyway and then
like we drank a lot last night and
watched it and I was like so so happy
because I'm like oh my god I love it
just as much I saw I think it's really I
saw it when it first came out in the
drive-in yeah every night for about two
weeks because before I went to Brazil I
was still in SEMA military academy yeah
our house was the house of who we were
Renton was right next to driving oh so I
could go to the back wall and jump up on
top of a tree I could see all the movies
but I was never had the balls to jump
over and go to where one of the
microphones were where all the cars were
you know all the speakers were so you
could I couldn't hear it yeah I couldn't
hear it but I could watch and and I used
to go up there and watch yeah yeah so
for a long time I had never heard it
yeah I mean we didn't sound I just tried
to figure out what it was about you know
it's kind of cool and I have a radio
going listening to like you know
Carriacou or something k-rock yeah yeah
that's kind of a shame because it's like
yeah you can follow the stories without
hearing them yeah but then you will be
robbed of your wonderful acting and
wonderful dialogue what's been around 13
nothing around 30 yeah it was after
mammoth mountain it was after that well
that yeah this came out in 82 um in the
theatres so I assume and sometimes it
took a little while for it to get to
drive-ins I think but maybe it was in a
whole year and then I think it came out
on home video 1983 but like I said I saw
it a million times in the 80s and I'm
really really glad like I was watching
it last night and I was like a little
bit liquored up you know what I mean but
I was sitting there going oh my god I
still love this movie it's even though I
remembered like every line of them I not
have been after it was around that time
it's either Africa before a little bit I
don't remember yeah okay it must've been
after yeah you're on yeah must been
after but if you don't know like I said
this is probably I think the best horror
anthology cuz I love horror anthology
movies and we've done a couple of them
on here we did Necronomicon body bags
and stuff like that and I like that
format yeah um the format was actually
pretty popular in the you know late 60s
early 70s with amicus productions which
was
in the UK which was kind of the
competitor to hammer they made like the
house that dripped blood and you know
vault what was it called
I don't know but there was a bunch of
those and those are really good but they
they'd always been played kind of
straight you know there was a straight
horror stories what this movie was and
this like listen to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is like the the horror loadstone
you know what I mean this is like all of
the best 80s horror [ __ ] like all coming
together in one wonderful super
entertaining package right so this was
directed by George Romero yeah written
by Stephen King based on some of his
stories and he also wrote some original
ones or this it had like amazing it had
an amazing amazing cast
agent Barbeau is in this yeah Stephen
King isn't vivica Lynn firs is in this
yeah it's Weaver is in this [ __ ] eg
Marshall is in that there's like Ted
Danson isn't it Leslie Nielsen yeah it's
like it's an amazing amazing movie it's
five stories and they are based on the
EC horror comics of the 1950's that both
George Romero and Stephen King grew up
really liking so there they were very
gory I mean EC Comics like their whole
they had a whole bunch of different ones
vault of fear and all these other
different ones
yeah and they were pretty much
single-handedly responsible for the for
the comics code that came out a flick in
the late 50s because they were so so
gory yeah and you know all the moral and
people back in back in the early 80s
some you know a person my age she was
you know 12 13 14 15 I immediately
understood what was going on when I saw
the comic book motif you know yeah
threading the stories together even
though I couldn't hear it because we
were growing up reading eerie and creepy
yeah and those are some badass and never
lost so heavy metal but those are some
badass comic books they weren't really
comic books are more like Illustrated
magazines yeah they were you know big
and they're cool okay you know and I
think they weren't full color though
yeah no they weren't full yeah these
ones were like heavy metal was but I
don't I don't think eerie and creepy
were they were [ __ ] bad though they
were really creepy yeah and and the
drawing and it was like really fancy
like I said they were super super gory
for the time and like they there was a
crackdown later on where this like
comics had to have readings yeah just
because they don't want kids eating dead
people yeah so like I said where's the
seventies yeah
George Romero and Stephen King both grew
up on these comics and even they
actually met when because I didn't know
this but George Romero was actually
supposed to direct the adaptation of
Salem's Lot which was actually supposed
to be a theatrical release but then they
said no we're gonna make it for TV we're
gonna make it a miniseries and tobe
Hooper is gonna do it and then George
Romero actually wanted to do the stand
yeah but they were like no no no studio
wanted to do that they're like no it's a
huge book it's gonna be really long and
all this other stuff so then Romero was
like okay well I want to do something
with Stephen King he's like I've always
wanted to do an anthology movie now his
original idea was which each story was
going to be from a different period of
you know horror movie history like he
was gonna do like sort of a universal
monster type thing then he was gonna do
like a 50s like big bug type or you know
that kind of movie and he was gonna do
one like from each decade but then him
and Stephen King got to talking they're
like no let's do one that's based on EC
comics because they both really really
like those and like I said they're super
gory and they're all like morality tales
it's always like um that's why the
documentary about the making of
Creepshow is called just desserts
because that's pretty much the theme of
every single story is that it's a
horrible person who gets revenge yeah
the whole theme oh let me jump in here
they are kind of gory and they are
creepy but there's kind of a
light-hearted fun that runs the whole
thing to me the movie always kind of had
a Spielberg Ian flare to it yeah it
wasn't like you were seeing like a
low-budget horror movie you know
grindhouse or anything it was kind it
was more like you were seeing almost
like a mainstream Steven Spielberg movie
that was for the family but I don't know
what kind of weird-ass family would
watch this it was weird
the little boy in the story with the
voodoo doll and every and his dad and it
was you just have to see it I mean it's
like kind of like watching a perverted
et or perverted verdict yeah you know
thought about or like a perverted
version of poltergeist it was because I
think the best thing about this movie um
and if I didn't mention it Tom Savini
and I [ __ ] love Tom Savini like III
that was another thing that I watched a
million times in the 80s was the
documentary that was about him and there
was a lot of [ __ ] stuff about Creepshow
in there in that documentary too about
the creatures and stuff that he made but
um even though this is great over the
top it's like a lot of horrible things
happen to like you know what I mean
but that said this is a fun movie yeah
like it's there's a lot of like dark
humor in it yeah you can tell that
everyone involved was having a [ __ ]
blast making this and there's like so
much affection for use on rrah
for the original comic books yeah we're
dialing in they were really like all the
actors that were in this did they
[ __ ] committed man they said we're
gonna do and we're gonna do like these
fun like over-the-top sort of archetypal
characters and they just went for it and
it really really works yeah and the
quality especially for the time it still
kind of holds up oh you have to see it
on blu-ray I guess because if it's the
Cobblers did look a lot better yeah and
actually I've heard the blu-ray transfer
because we were debating last night
because we saw the DVD I was like it's
like clean up better because you know
it's from the 80s and sometimes movies
from the 80s kind of suffer when you
know you try to make them clean yeah you
see a minute
obviously it's happening on a set now
just like one of my favorite more newer
movies from the 90s which is cart
Russell's soldier looks great until you
put it till you see it on blu-ray on a
really good really really high
definition television all of a sudden
you go madness of six it's happening on
a soundstage
it looks very looks cheap weird it looks
very weird but it looks better in an
original DVD a comb at or a lower
resolution then it all kinds it and ends
up looking kind of like alien for you
know felt like that level but I have to
say like from everything I've
the blu-ray transfer of Creepshow then
it actually looks beautiful that the
movie like cleaned up really nice
because you know what I mean it's
supposed to look like a comic book and
one thing that's cool about this is that
yeah they make it look like a comic book
like some of the panels they use like a
lot of Dutch angles and like you know
they kind of have a page turning wipe
and they have like all these bright
colors that happen and like
illustrations to combine that people and
stuff but it's not done in a way that's
distracting from the actual stories like
it's just kind of happens in between and
then you just watch the story unfold and
then so it's kind of a transitional
feature yeah and so it's not it's not a
case where the style is just like
overwhelming the story you can still
enjoy the stories even though they still
look very comic book ask yeah and so I
think that's like one of the best things
about it and like I said so we're gonna
do I'm you know I'm gonna kind of go
through the little store I don't want to
ruin it if people haven't seen it cuz I
know we have like some younger listeners
and yeah you haven't seen it this is
this and you don't want to spoil
something on at this level because it
would be like spoiling poltergeist or et
had you never seen it yeah and it's
about that same levels of 80s quality
although the writing I think this is a
letter yeah Dola g film with like along
the lines of the stories are kinda like
along the lines of say like really good
Twilight Zone episode like morality play
yeah with good good Tom Savini style
like special effects yeah he did all the
effects really yeah so it's good but
yeah so it's it's lovingly crafted it
really is it really is like I said you
can tell everybody involved really good
animation just leave it there yeah now
the interesting thing about this Romero
up to this point this was actually his
biggest budget it cost eight million
dollars because it was a major major
studio behind him but he did film it in
Pittsburgh like he filmed most of his
other stuff and used most of his you
know friends and his hometown crew and
people he liked you know to work with
and stuff like that most of the stuff
was filmed on a set they actually least
a abandoned girls school like a academy
and built a film studio in there
essentially
yeah so pretty much all the stuff like
Jordy Verrill in the second segment his
whole house that's
that they built some of the stuff was
filmed on-location like the first part
Father's Day that was kind of in a
mansion that was filmed in a mansion and
you know some of the beach was filmed in
New Jersey and stuff like that but most
of the stuff was sets that they built
and also the kid it's this is actually
they you know buddy says five stories
anthos really six because there's like a
wraparound yeah everyone sort of ties it
all together it has Tom Atkins in it
that was in Halloween 3 and he was in
the fog and Tom Savini is in it and
Romero at the end yeah and yeah yeah
it's not needy yet but with him at the
garbage truck uh I can't remember
actually yeah they're all inserting
themselves in this movie yeah but um the
kid in the beginning like I said Tom
Atkins plays his dad and he's like what
is this creep show this comic book crap
yeah won't you read this crap so abusive
the little kid that's in that that's
Stephen King's son Joe yeah um who
actually as most of you probably know if
you're horror fans went on to become a
very successful horror novelist in his
home right under the name Joe Hill I've
actually read a bunch of his books
particularly horns is very good if you
haven't read it they made a movie out of
it with Daniel Radcliffe a Perry Potter
Fame but that man was actually the movie
was actually pretty good Stephen King
plays a crazy ass yes Stephen King is in
know yes and he does a good job early
for his first time on screen he does a
real good job because he's goofy anyway
and that's who this character you know
he's real goofy he just plays that the
goofy yeah
let's let's talk a little bit I'm just
gonna go through the well nothing yeah
I'm not gonna so I'm just gonna go
through like the five stories and say
was there in the first story it's hard
to pick a favorite but I think are all
good spy clothes they're all good yeah
if somebody put a gun to my head and
said I had to pick a favorite segment it
would be the first one father's day for
some I don't know why I really love I
love the back-and-forth between like the
snotty rich characters my favorite thing
about it is vivica Lynn firs as Aunt
Bedelia she is wonderful she's only in
it for like a few minutes it's only like
a few minutes of screen time but her
drunken ass like sitting on that gray
zone like
the Jim Beam and like yelling at her dad
and all the other kind of [ __ ] I [ __ ]
love that she's so awesome in this yeah
I said earlier they were kind of like
Twilight Zone yeah episodes actually
they're more like really good night
gallery episodes yeah the night gallery
was a little bit better if you ask me
some of the stuff and also to and I had
forgotten about this but I definitely
want to mention it in the Father's Day
segment the zombie revenant whatever the
corpse that crawls out yeah do you know
who's in there that's John and les who
played Martin George Ramirez okay which
we also did Oh Ohio tide you over was
the good one Leslie Nielsen plays this
psychopathic guy who's getting revenge
on his wife and his wife's lover fooling
around on him yeah that was pretty good
too good yeah that's that's the third
segment that one yeah we're going in
order yeah okay but yeah so actually the
first ones probably my favorite like I
said cuz I just like all the all the
character she's the interplay between
the the character actors and it's it's
almost kind of like a long yeah joke
sort of like at the end you know the
punch line and everything now the second
one the second one is the most divisive
among fans of the show because this is
the one that has Stephen King in it in
his acting debut called The Lonesome
death of Jordi barrel how could that be
divisive well I'm just it that was
awesome I'm just saying like at the time
cuz sometimes always a little bit over
the top now I should be noted that
George Romero the direction that he gave
Stephen King was act like Wiley coyote
falling off a cliff yeah that's what he
told them
so he's like very bug-eyed and
everything like that but actually I
think that works really well like
because it's supposed to be a comedy
yeah that's a shop yeah he's like this
over-the-top like country bumpkin yokel
type of character and I'd the best thing
about this is his fantasies about what's
gonna happen like is basically it's just
he lives on this farm by himself after
his father died and he's kind of you
know he's kind of simple
yeah meteor coming here he's gonna be
like a blob but it's not kinda kinda and
stuff like that so just his funny lot
like the way he's all like his eyes are
like meteor [ __ ] you know what I mean
yeah I [ __ ] love it yeah you can't
you have to understand what the source
material was these comic books that were
like this like eerie and creepy
they were different some of the stories
were some of the some of the stories in
them were plausible some of them were
impossible
modern modern-day kids may be like this
that can't happen SF but yes it's
impossible but what if it did happen
no no what if it did and and that's that
was part of the element that used to get
me as a kid reading these comics and be
like that can't happen but man but what
if that did happen and then your
imagination start running away with you
so don't fight the stories just enjoy
them like yeah okay it's been in that
box since 1832 okay the second one I
think is actually the one that could
actually happen yeah yeah it's not that
likely yeah yeah it's basically just
panspermia yeah
something another plan but like I said
my favorite aspect of this other than
like Stephen King's like he's just so
funny in this he's so funny in this dude
but I love his fantasies about like who
he's gonna get all this money a whole
two hundred dollars from this meteor
like from the from the College of
meteors just like really funny but yeah
so that's the second segment the third
one is called something to tide you over
yeah I like that and this it's
straight-up revenge stories like Leslie
Nielsen plays this you know rich guy
who's kind of a psychopath and finds out
that his wife who was actually in Dawn
of the Dead
she has been fooling around on him with
Ted Danson yeah and so he decides to
exact revenge on them yeah that's as far
as you can go you can't be acting in
this room is fantastic I love the inner
play like the the conversations between
Leslie Nielsen and Ted Danson
I mean Leslie Nielsen he'd been and you
know live in airplane and all this other
stuff so he had done straight roles
before but he's kind of best known for
doing comedic roles but in this one he
is like straight up evil and he's
terrifying he's really really good in
this the reason why he played a lot of
comedy roles though is because
was known for straight-up rolls yeah but
he knocked it out of the park so hard on
airplane and from there on out he got
tidy just got typecast as this is this
serious guy who's not supposed to be
doing comedy who's really funny and yeah
yeah but in this like be like have a
Robert Stack do comedy
exactly well now I'm kind of bummed out
that I never know yeah it's a similar
type dinah imagine Robert Stack got
typecast as being funny bait on the back
of what he did with unsolved mystery
like that yeah but that's what it's like
so like I said I think I think people of
our generation that didn't grow up with
Leslie Nielsen on the you know all their
older TV shows where he played like a
straight man yeah um kind of you know
because he was in all the sucker movies
and everything like that where he was
funny and then he just got he played
Blake mr. Magoo and chillin yeah but in
this is all on a back of airplane yeah
but in this he plays like he has funny
lines yeah but the the funny things that
he says like you know enhance his
evilness yeah and so he plays it really
really good he's really really scary I
went back saw airplane it wasn't fine
it's not as fun well because I feel more
doesn't age well it totally doesn't I
mean some things that I saw many years
later that were still funny Ghostbusters
the first good shows are still funny um
Beverly Hills cops still funny I used to
think any Murphy raw was real funny went
back to saw that routine I was like yeah
it was funny back then but it's not
funny I wonder if it's just because you
know all the jokes I don't know I don't
know I think just the Overton Window is
expanded to a point where everybody
talks like that now he was saying that
in public
anytime when you weren't supposed to be
saying that I guess soundstage but yeah
so anyway so then the fourth one which
is actually a lot of people's favorite
segment is called the crate that's a
good one and it's actually the longest
one it's the one that highlights
Adrienne Barbeau they creature effects
of Tom Savini and also Adrienne Barbeau
is in it being my spirit animal yes she
is like so funny in this she's like
she's supposed to be like super
unpleasant super shrewish she's just
like his horrible drunken obnoxious
woman who's married to this kind of
mild-mannered professor who has all
these like fantasies about killing her
and stuff but it's like she is [ __ ]
great it is I love her so much noiz
struck me as a
as a chick that was cool like in real
life she seemed like a very cool she
does seem like seventies eighties
yeah called chicks back then yeah but
yeah so just have to be a chicks am i
tough enough to be a baby maybe maybe
maybe yeah you're alright alright you're
right right
but yeah so I really do love so the
whole thing it's like these professors
and they find this crate that's hidden
underneath the stairs has been there
from like yeah don't say anything about
the crime right Sam not they just find
it and then you know things happen that
have to do with the professor and his
why his wife yes but she's I just love
her I love her in this she's like in at
the party with she's got like constantly
got a drink in her hand
yeah and she's just like Emily
Vanderbilt or Emily very very whoever
that etiquette crotch is she's [ __ ]
great at this so yeah that's like I said
the crate is is usually the the segment
that most people point out is their
favorite yeah that's what the last one
was about it the last one
he's a germaphobe didn't like bugs eg
Marshall ISM yeah playing a very Scrooge
like basically played Scrooge like a
high-tech Scrooge and a real sterilized
Howard Department yeah I've been up in
he's in mad at Hell's Kitchen yeah he's
in Hell's Kitchen he says so yeah it's a
thirty six hundred dollar apartment back
then in Hell's Kitchen and it just looks
like a hospital and he's got bug
problems yeah but there's other K the
bugs kind of an analogy for also like
competitors and employees against his
businesses and also it's kind of a
racism metaphor too because he does like
the guy he talks to you through them the
exterminator he talks to you yeah maybe
yesterday no it is this is it a beer
okay it is but um the the thing about
this segment was that like I'm from
Florida
you guys and it's like we have big bugs
now I'm not creeped out by I'm not
bothered by spiders I'm not bothered by
snakes rats or anything like that but
for some reason roaches grossed me the
[ __ ] out
so this final segment always really
really bothered ya always really
bothered me
bad ass roach infestation yeah and like
it serious you were Roach phobic yeah
this is gonna freak you the [ __ ] out
because this it's and no CGI in 1982 oh
it's real roaches mostly they had to
this is like what what did we determine
it was like 250 [ __ ] like there was over
$100,000 worth of cockroach yeah they
got him from Trinidad and [ __ ] like that
it's [ __ ] horrifying yeah and it's
like it and I loved in the in the
credits it's like roots Wrangler and
it's just like when I was watching it
last night like I drug it's like oh god
I forgot they don't bother me I mean the
little ones you know I don't like this
because this is a cockroaches but the
giant ones that we have here they're
most of them live outside they eat these
damn rotten palm trees and stuff yeah
and they're so big they can't infest but
this guy's got a huge of that station a
station well you you gotta think to like
I said I grew up in Florida so I have
had these are some things that I have
had happened to me there Roach related
okay um I have had I put on a shirt that
was hanging in my closet and I had a
huge cockroach crawl out of the pocket
when was this
this was a long time ago when I looked
at my grandmother's house alright um I
was sleeping one night and felt
something go like right into my tits big
cockroach on my chest
yeah they were so they were so big that
sometimes she would wake up in the
middle of night and in the darkened
bedroom and you could hear them crawling
along the wall their little [ __ ]
scuttling legs and [ __ ] oh my god and
also I've put on like slip-on shoes and
had one crawl out over my foot must have
had an infestation there was that mole
house yeah it was the house from the 50s
yeah because some of those some of the
house especially the older houses there
they could get in them yeah yeah I think
got in through the air conditioning you
know yeah cuz we had a window unit air
conditioning we didn't
central error house didn't have central
air um yeah so we it wasn't like
infested but during the summer it was
hard to keep them out because there's
just yeah the kind of house that red
cool down yeah and we just had like
there were palm trees all over the yard
it kind of lived in them they eat does
yeah so we had them come in quite often
and I really really really developed a
horrible horrible phobia of them so like
I said this last segment which if I
didn't mention it is called they're
creeping up on you really really upsets
me yeah and it like it just made me like
oh I need to take a shower and [ __ ]
bleach but whatever yeah so um and also
I want to say and then at the end
there's like the the you know kind of
wrap around segment again with the kid
and the dad I love revenge on the kid
yeah I love I love Tom Savini he's he's
in this for maybe like 15 seconds and he
plays like a garbage man yeah and I just
love his life and like their you know
they're like looking through the thing
it's like oh we can't get that you know
I mean it's just they're very funny and
like I said you know I see this
classified as like a horror comedy I
don't know if I'd go so far as to call
it a comedy um
it is funny like it has like a lot of
dark humor in it but it's also still
kind of a horror movie its gory it's
their skin like creepy parts but it's
just the you know the the main word that
I want to use is it's just really fun
it's a fun affectionate movie and it's
just I never get tired of it I just yeah
I didn't know I didn't know maybe if it
was like nostalgia or how well it held
up I went back and looked at it know
held up real well it did I think real
well and we saw some reviews some
younger guys made they liked it too they
call this awesome movie yeah yeah it
goes how can you not it's their loveable
if the tone of the movie throughout and
just the craftsman the craftsmanship of
the movie kind of holds up you from from
the very beginning you're not supposed
to be taking this movie seriously so
therefore you don't have to worry about
the plausibility of these stories that's
not what it's about if the whole things
about tone having fun morality tales and
that's what that's what the source
material was like with those comics yeah
I mean though it's right there yeah
they really nailed the road tone
correctly and like I said it's funny
because I know this is gonna sound weird
but it's like you you don't take the
movie seriously but everybody involved
with it took its ear yeah making it to
make it like a really good movie cuz you
could tell everyone that was in this was
committed they it's just such a it's a
love letter to the genre really I I
think and you can really tell that
really comes through every frame of this
movie it's just it's a really nice
looking movie like I like all the comic
transitions I love all the girls lights
and all the stuff like showing up behind
people in the little comic pan yes but
their stories and their stories just
like Night Gallery stories yeah people
don't crawl up out of graves for no
reason all right
things don't think I can survive in
[ __ ] lock boxes for 137 years it just
can't happen alright but no but what if
it did yeah that's what the movies what
if it didn't what if it did happen every
now and then yeah and some of these
actually kind of could have like I said
the second one that could happen yeah
yeah brooch thing yeah yeah it's
horrible no no it's an I'm gonna have to
like make like a overlay of like witches
curls I'm not gonna do that I can't even
like look at a fixture of the fun things
but yeah so if you haven't seen creep
show if you like anthology movies if you
love 80s horror I can't imagine that you
haven't seen creep chicks I've already
seen classic yeah um easily the best
horror anthology
now I'm actually you're 15 and you
haven't seen the creep show you I go see
it yeah I've heard that actually um the
the anthology would be trick-or-treat is
almost as good as this and I you know I
I hate to say but I haven't seen it yet
it's on my list I just haven't got
around to it I don't remember
so to Creepshow to was not that good it
was only three stories they didn't get
as big a budget and um you know I don't
even remember I remember two of the
stories but I don't remember what the
third one was I remember the raft one
was all right if you've seen Creepshow
and haven't seen body bags and like
Creepshow see body bags
that's similar yeah it's similar I mean
obviously [ __ ] shows a lot better yeah
but body bags is still pretty good too
yeah and you know but like I said creep
show is kind of like the granddaddy of
you know all the comic book movies and
also anthology movies and it kind of
spurred an eight
he's renaissance in anthology films I
mean a lot of the anthology films that
came out in the 80s were because of
creeps you because it was a big success
I've actually heard that they're trying
to make a new TV show based on this
which I'm assuming is going to be on
shudder or Netflix or something like
that so we'll see how that goes I think
they just announced it once ago remember
Tales from the Crypt yeah that TV show
that was yeah that was a song for you I
remember pretty good but just never
really caught on with me I was there
doing other things at the time yeah I
mean it was a good show I liked some of
them but you know you just can't you
can't match Creepshow it's just it's so
fun and actually Tales from the Crypt
must have been inspired by this yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's where that's where
that whole thing in like right the one
they did that was based on Nightmare on
Elm Street like Freddy's nightmares or
whatever it was that also came in light
of this well the window tales of the
Crypt one can't come out what the TV
show of the movie when they're a movie
there were maybe three weren't called
there was um bordello of blood yeah
that's right there was a demon night and
then there was a third one but I can't
remember the name of it but were they
anthologies no those things they weren't
okay they were just kind of like
extended denzel's from the Crypt episode
yeah that's like wrap arounds with the
Crypt Keeper okay so they weren't
anthology films I never got into them so
I didn't know much bones yeah they
weren't bad you know demon night with a
little bit better thing was kind of
annoying so yeah like I could see what
they were trying to do but like I said
it wasn't it wasn't as fun as creep show
was because [ __ ] what is fun is
Elvira
well yeah looks great yeah we just saw
her it was that last year she's yeah
looks fantastic yep she doesn't she she
is like unchanged pretty much I think
she bathes in virgin blood yeah
so like I said if you if you're younger
you haven't seen Creepshow and you like
eighties horror movies you really need
to see creep so it's easily the best
former anthology it's super fun it's
super entertaining every story is good
and you know it just has a great
aesthetic eighties it yeah it is it's
very eighties but it's really I mean
it's a [ __ ]
music and like I said I [ __ ] love
this movie I could just watch it over
and over and I'm really glad that we saw
it again and I it held up because I was
afraid it might not because I saw it so
many times in the 80s and then I haven't
seen it for 15 or 20 years but yeah I
still loved it just as much it was good
yeah check it out and remember if you
like the show to like share subscribe on
all your social media share with all
your friends and also if you'd like to
financially support the show as you know
you can go to our patreon page which is
patreon calm and clock podcast or you
can go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress.com and there's link
in the sidebar to a PayPal account if
you'd like to give a one-time donation
and remember that our regular episodes
go up every Tuesday and our movie
retrospectives come out every Friday and
that will do it for this installment we
will see you next time bye meteor ship
you